with these own resources we will
ensure that it is not the
citizens who will reimburse for the
recovery
we need a budget for the author of the
needs of the challenges we have at this time
[Music]
it is financed  we say by
own resources but that the truth they are
not géluines own resources
most of the money which comes to the budget
it comes from the Member States and
then other resources it is the
VAT resource or a part of the customs duties  for
example
we have major transitions to finance
the climate transition the
digital transition if we do not have new
own resources it will be serious
why because we will have a
budget reduction of more than 10% after 2027
we want revenue
from  sufficient own resources
so as not to cut the muscles shaved
research programs defense
civil protection programs
cohesion policy agriculture
they come to bring back
fiscal and social justice  ale
[Music]
it's the revision of the carbon market
it's the famous
carbon border adjustment mechanism
it's the taxation of revenues from
the taxation of large
multinationals euros per year which is at the  objective
of paying the Next I would like Chenu
when we launched the acc
generation program, that is to say a
recovery plan to deal with the consequences
of the health crisis, we made
the collective commitment that these
are not the  citizens who were going to
reimburse but the actors who do
not pay their just taxes
today companies that pollute
[Music]